every man is responsible for everything
that happens to him and everything that
happens to everyone else everything is
your fault even when it's not the
brilliant insight that changes
everything for people is realizing that
responsibility is never given it's taken
rise and shine it's an Express no time
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message take
responsibility over to you Jordan B
Peterson one of the things that's really
interesting about the Old Testament is
that and the Jews in the Old Testament
is that they don't take the path of Cain
every time they're walloped by God which
is like fairly frequently they say we
must have done something wrong and we
have to set our self right and that's a
an unbelievably heroic attitude because
that's the alternative to cursing fate
it's like you take the responsibility
for failure unto yourself and you think
well if I was just maybe if I just had
my act together a little bit more if I
took advantage of every opportunity that
was put in front of me if I wasn't
resentful and bitter then I could have
done something that would have tilted
the situation in a different direction
and like that's almost inevitably true
Dostoevsky I think said something like
every man is responsible for everything
that happens to him and everything that
happens to everyone else and that's you
know that that's that's it's a crazy
statement right it's a crazy statement
and he was a pretty extreme person in
many many ways but there's a level at
which that's metaphysically true you
know because what happens is that it's
you its failure to act often that's the
most catastrophic you know I mean it's
it's it's to not do the right thing when
the when the situation presents itself
it's very specific you know you're
constantly in situations where you could
do the right thing if you were willing
to take a risk that's actually of
relatively moderate size and you know
that you could take the risk and you
know that you should take the risk and
you don't and that happens to people all
the time and then what happens is the
thing that they didn't oppose grows a
little bit and they shrink a little bit
and that starts a loop hey the minute
that you start to accept responsibility
for everything your life is the minute
that you start to win great leaders
accept responsibility for everything
that is happening around them in their
business in their life it's what great
leaders do great leaders are not blaming
their mom they're not blaming their team
they're not blaming the president when
something doesn't happen according to
the way that they want it to happen
great leaders don't just take credit
when everything is good great lives in
fact you should give credit to their
team but then they own the
responsibility they own the mistakes
everything is their fault on the surface
that might seem a little extreme that
might seem like a crazy burden to bear
that idea that everything is your fault
even when it's not everything is your
fault
even when it's not it's an unfair burden
to bear but when you do it why it's so
amazing why it leads to ultimate
happiness why ultimately sets you free
is because now it's in your control if
you believe you have the responsibility
then you can also believe that you can
change it you can make an impact you can
make a difference you can solve it but
as long as it's somebody else's fault
you can't as long as it's the
president's fault the economy's fault
your customers fault as long as somebody
else's fault
it feels great because you can blame
somebody else but you can't fix it and
so great leaders accept the
responsibility that it's their fault
and then they go off and make a change
everything that happens in my business
everything happens in my life and in all
my businesses it's all my fault some
quick examples we had to get some books
out I had some science and books had to
get to some of the fans and customers
and I customized each one I wrote a
message on the inside of each book
nee-naw my wife was in charge of sending
them out and she didn't open up the book
to see that I had customized
she just thought I had a default
signature and she just piled any book
into the envelope and sent it off and so
Yoko got a book that said dear Nathan
and so we had to write to everybody and
say we're really sorry we messed up you
know let us send you another book that
has a proper name on it that's my fault
right is it Nina's fault yeah but it's
my fault I own it it's my fault because
I didn't tell Nina that this was
happening I wasn't clear in the
instructions ultimately it was my
decision to give it to her it's my fault
it's my fault it's my fault it's my
fault
in parenting it's my fault in these
videos it's my fault we did a day of
shooting where my microphone didn't work
and we filmed how many videos I don't
know how many videos how many videos
have we filmed like 40 videos 60 videos
a lot of videos I'm a microphone didn't
work so the audio is being picked up by
the camera which is across the room and
it's super echoey and some of my best
videos are on that super Ecklie camera
that's my fault
I mean it's Jason's fault really Jason's
here but it's my fault it's my fault
it's ultimately it's my fault right I
should have done a sound check I
shouldn't made sure that everything was
set up properly it's my fault that that
happened and so I encourage you strongly
to think about everything that's
happening like why are you not more
successful look in the mirror ask
yourself why are you not more successful
what's the reason that comes to mind
unless the answer comes back that it's
you then it's BS then it's just excuses
then it's just blaming somebody else
it's not your mom's fault you're not
more successful it's not Donald Trump's
fault you're not more successful it's
not your high school teachers fault
you're not more successful it's you it's
you you are the reason you are not more
successful you are your biggest asset
and your biggest liability you are
getting in your own way your lack of
skills energy ability passion is what is
holding you back right now and use that
it's again a kick forward not a kick
down don't use that that pile on crap on
top of yourself and say well I suck I'm
never going to get better and it's not
my fault and what was me and and life is
terrible I should just stay in a hole
and never come out did a lot of people
do and it's really unfortunate and sad
because there's a way through yes it's
your fault but that means you
change it that means you can get better
if you get better the problem will go
away if you learn this skill the problem
will go away if you touch these buttons
the problem will go away and so if you
think that any problem in your life is
your fault and you have the ability to
change it and make a difference and make
a mark that's when you start to win now
I have a really special bonus gift for
you but before that question today I
want to know what is one negative thing
happen in your life right now that you
are going to own responsibility for and
say that that thing is happening that's
my fault
leave in the comments below all really
curious to figure it out thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Music]
do for a really long time that school is
a scam that teaches people to be
compliant that tells you to only listen
to things that are on the test
encourages you to do the minimum amount
because whatever you get away was the
rest of the times yours that's what we
teach you in school we invented that so
that you would get a factory job and do
what you were told
because factories needed it so that's
why they invented school and the
brilliant insight that changes
everything for people is realizing that
responsibility is never given it's taken
and then if you choose to take
responsibility all these doors open up
and that you get a totally different
life in exchange because striving for
authority hoping someone will give you a
license to tell other people what to do
that's pretty rare but if you're willing
to take responsibility then no one can
get in your way what were you working at
McDonald's and that was an acting
training ground for you well what else
is what you make your purchases I mean I
so I went to UCLA I was a literature
major my friend my dad want to be mean
to be a math major I wanted to go to art
school to compromise that I say
literature once I got to UCLA I realized
you know half the towns in the movie
business and suddenly I saw that there
were practical steps I could take to get
into the movies and I didn't seem to be
doing that you know in my Milton class
you know it just seemed like the long
road to I didn't even know where and so
I eventually dropped out of UCLA after a
year went to acting school in the valley
and my parents said they wouldn't
support me if I wasn't going to
university and so I had to get a job and
I couldn't you know all the other actors
had been you know they were they got all
the great waiting jobs and somebody said
you too good to work at McDonald's I
said no and you know it was a you know
cuz I I wanted to be an actor I knew
they felt like that was the only way I
would I would be able to do it it was
not it was a really important lesson
actually that you know going in and
working and being responsible for myself
really showed me how much I wanted dad
like it wasn't the soft way you know I
had to really work for it to take no
less than 100% responsibility for your
life you know one of the greatest myths
that's pervasive in our culture today is
that you're entitled to a great life in
the somehow somewhere someone is
responsible for filling our lives with
continual happiness and exciting career
options a nurturing family and blissful
personal relationships simply because we
exist but the real truth is that there's
only one person responsible for the
quality of your life and that person is
you you see everything about you is a
result of your doing or not doing your
income your debt your relationships your
health your fitness level your attitudes
and behaviors everything that person you
see when you look in the mirror is the
chief architect in your life you know I
think everybody knows this in their
heart of hearts but the mind can play
games tricking us into thinking that
there are external factors that are the
source of our failures our
disappointments and our unhappiness but
the truth of the matter is that external
factors don't determine how you live you
and only you are in complete control of
the quality of your life experience
successful people take full
responsibility for the thoughts they
think the images they visualize and the
actions they take they don't waste their
time and energy on blaming and
complaining they evaluate their
experiences and decide if they need that
we're not they face the uncomfortable
and they take risks in order to create
the life that they want to live full
volume you have the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details